MALE SPEAKER: Welcome
everybody to one more Authors
at Google Talk.
Today with us is Hampton
Sides with his new book
"In the Kingdom of Ice."
In the late 19th
century, people were
obsessed by one of the
last unmapped areas
of the globe, the North Pole.
No one knew what existed
beyond the fortress of ice
rimming the northern oceans.
Well, the theories about
the foremost cartographer
of the world, a German
named August Petermann,
believed that warm currents
sustained at green island
at the top of the world.
National glory would
fall to whoever could
plant his flag upon its shores.
James Gordon Bennett, the
eccentric and stupendously
wealthy owner of
the New York Herald,
had recently captured
the world's attention
by dispatching Stanley to Africa
to find Doctor Livingstone.
Now he was keen to recreate that
sensation on an even more epic
scale.
So he founded an official
US Naval expedition
to reach the Pole,
choosing as its captain
a young officer named
George Washington DeLong.
On July 8, 1879,
the USS Jeanette
set sail from San Francisco.
They faced everything from
snow blindness, polar bears,
ferocious storms, frosted
labyrinths, madness,
and starvation.
This is a tale of
heroism and determination
in the most unforgiving
territory on Earth.
Hampton Sides is an
award winning editor
of "Outside," a
frequent contributor
to "National Geographic,"
and the author of bestselling
histories "Hellbound on His
Trail," of "Blood and Thunder,"
and "Ghost Soldiers."
Please, join me in
welcoming Hampton to Google.
HAMPTON SIDES: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
It's good to be here.
I had a bit of an adventure
just getting here.
They dropped me
off at a building
about 12 or 13 buildings
over, and it was sort of
like wandering
around in the Arctic.
But I got here.
What an extraordinary,
extraordinary place to work.
The paperback version of
"In the Kingdom of Ice"
just came out two days ago,
so I'm now on a book tour.
I was in Seattle yesterday, but
I'm moving about the country.
And I always ask
people when I first
begin to talk about the
Voyage of the Jeanette,
barring those of you
who maybe already read
the book, how many
of you had heard
of the Voyage of the
Jeanette prior to this?
Big goose egg.
Yup.
And that's exactly what I
encounter everywhere I go.
And that's exactly the
reason why I wrote this book.
When I first heard about this
while I was on an assignment
with "National Geographic"
to write about another Arctic
explorer in Oslo, the great
scientist and explorer Fridtjof
Nansen.
I saw in the museum there in
Oslo all these references,
continuing references to
the Jeanette expedition,
the famous American voyage
from the Gilded Age.
And I'm an American.
I said, well, why
haven't I heard of this?
What is the Jeanette?
And sometimes it takes asking
just an obvious question
like that to begin
to bore into a story.
And so I came home.
I began to read the
primary documents
and got really, really
interested in this story.
It took me three years to do it.
I traveled all over Siberia, and
the high Arctic, and the Bering
Strait, and all over
America in pursuit of it.
I had of ball doing
this story, and I'm
going to today talk
with you a little bit
about some of my travels in
pursuit of the Jeanette story
and give you some of the
background about what
the expedition was about.
The men of the
Jeanette that survived,
they returned home
as great heroes.
They were household names.
They were lauded and celebrated.
There were blockbuster newspaper
stories and magazines stories.
There were parades in Manhattan.
There were monuments erected
to them all over the country.
The survivors were
entertained by the Czar
of Russia, Alexander III.
The story was the subject
of bestselling books.
The journals and
diaries of the commander
became a bestselling book.
But it's completely
obscure today
as the numbers here bear
it's a story that slipped
through the cracks of history.
One place though where it is
quite well known is this place.
This is the Jeanette Monument at
the Naval Academy in Annapolis
where George DeLong
and his men are
celebrated as part of the
Pantheon of great Navy explorer
heroes.
And when I was on the book
tour, a former midshipman
came up to me at some
point and said, yeah,
the Jeanette Memorial.
That's something that they
used to always require us,
almost like a hazing ritual,
at midnight to go and count
the number of icicles
on the monument
and report back to the
authorities or whatever.
I guess it's your
tax dollars at work.
OK, so the Voyage
of the Jeanette
was really based on trying
to prove or disprove
an old, old idea,
an old theory that
goes back as far as the
Greeks and the Vikings
but really came
to be crystallized
in this map, a 1592 Mercator
map which showed very clearly
an open polar sea.
Through the ice in
this symmetrical way,
they believed there were portals
that led through the ice,
and that it was warm up there,
and that there was an iron
mountain in the center of
it, which of course explains
why compasses work.
Obviously, a flawed
idea, but once you
get an idea like that
enshrined in a map, especially
a beautiful map, and a widely
circulated and important map,
it becomes increasingly
difficult to dislodge that idea
from the public imagination.
So what you really had
was several centuries
of scientists, and
pseudoscientists, and sometimes
cranks, and various
authors and explorers
who tried to prove or
disprove the existence
of this fantastical
body of water.
Open polar sea.
Of course, the
Vikings had an idea.
It was called Ultima Thule,
someplace beyond the ice where
it was warm year round.
And there were various
tropical and exotic animals
believed to be there.
The Greeks had Hyperborea, which
they talked about, and believed
that there was beyond
the ice, again,
a mountain range where
the Griffons lived,
half lion, half eagle.
In the 1800s though,
you begin to get
a bunch of really bizarre ideas
coming out of particularly
the United States.
John Cleves Symmes was
one of these cranks who
believed that at the
top of the world,
there were these big holes
that led down into the Earth,
and that there were people
who lived down there.
And they were just dying
for us to go find them.
And he was very influential.
He sold out lecture
halls everywhere he went.
Members of Congress were
taken with his idea.
This is what it was
supposed to look
like from the pages of
"Harper's Magazine,"
Symmes's hole as it would appear
to a Lunarian with a telescope.
The hollow Earth theory,
holes at the poles,
this idea I thought a very
antiquarian, quixotic idea.
But then I googled
holes at the poles.
And lo and behold, there
is this large subculture.
I mean, not large
but fairly intense
subculture of people who
still believe that there
are holes at the poles.
And this is a supposedly
confiscated, censored NASA
photograph.
There are people down there.
They want us to find them,
but the administrators,
particularly the
Obama administration,
has done everything it can
to prevent us from knowing
about its existence.
So the idea has been
very slow to die.
And it seems to be fairly
deeply embedded in our psyche.
Jules Verne had popularized
the notion of an open polar sea
further with the publication
of his book, "Journey
to the Center of the Earth,"
although he brought it
underground.
There were subterranean
lakes that in his novel
figure into the story.
Mary Shelley, of course, was
fascinated with the North Pole.
Doctor Frankenstein pursues
his monster all the way
to the North Pole in the novel.
Now, moving beyond scientific
theory to just fact,
we know who lives
at the North Pole.
We know what's there.
Santa Clause is there.
And I thought this must
be a pretty old idea,
but when I was doing the
research for the book,
I found out that really the
idea of Santa being at the North
Pole came from this cartoon from
Harper's from the 1860s which
shows him with his helpers
and his workshop up there.
So during the 1860s
particularly, and 1870s,
and into the 1880s, you get
this intense polar fever that
begins to build, particularly
in the United States--
this nagging,
gnawing, need to know
what was at the top
of the world, one
of the last unmapped areas.
It drove people crazy.
And it also had an
element of nationalism
for the United States.
After the Civil War,
emerging from the devastation
of the Civil War, we
began to flex our muscles
around the world stage, wanting
to compete with the Brits who
had done most of exploring,
of the course the Russians
and some of the
Scandinavian countries.
But we wanted to stake
our claim in the Arctic
and had recently purchased
from the Russians Alaska.
And there was a real
curiosity about what
was north of our new territory.
No one had been there.
Some Arctic whalers had been
along the edges of the ice,
but no one had ever really
seen what was north of Alaska.
Now, there were a
number of scientists
who were interested
in this question
but also very much interested
in the open polar sea theory.
One of them was this
guy, Dr. August Petermann
who you alluded a to
in the introduction.
Petermann was the
foremost mapmaker
in the world at that time.
Google Maps had
nothing on this guy.
He produced these absolutely
beautiful hand colored but mass
produced maps that brought
in the latest findings
from explorers.
And they came back from
Africa, or they came back
from the interior of Australia.
He would pencil in
the new information.
And so these were up to date
and highly sought after maps.
And from this platform--
and he published
all these maps in Germany
in a place called Gotha.
And he was widely sought after.
He was popular in
the lecture circuit.
And on this platform,
by virtue of his maps,
he was able to promulgate his
various theories, almost all
of which were wrong, about what
was at the top of the world.
But people believed him
because he was erudite,
he was a German scholar, and he
also had excellent facial hair,
like a lot of the
characters in this book.
This is one of his master
works, "The Atlas of Physical
Geography."
His birthplace,
I went to Germany
and tried to begin to understand
his world and the power
of maps, the power especially
in that age when they were just
a few areas left
in the world that
had never been touched by man.
The monument to
Petermann in Gotha.
But this begins to show
a little of the theories
on which the Jeanette expedition
was based and Petermann's idea.
We were beginning to learn
that the Gulf Stream was
a powerful current that
brought a lot of heat
from the tropics north
through the Atlantic Ocean
and past England, past Norway.
No one knew precisely
where it went.
And Petermann's
theory was that it
met the ice, tunneled
under the ice,
softened the ice as it
went, and eventually went
to the North Pole.
There's another current
that they were also
beginning to learn about
on the Pacific side--
I don't know if you can
see that-- called the Kuro
Siwo, which is indeed a
powerful current in the Pacific
that goes north towards
the Bering Strait.
So his theory was
beautiful in its symmetry,
somewhat grandiose.
But it was that these two great
currents met at the North Pole
and it was part of a massive
thermo-regulation system
of the planet.
And the key word here
being "supposed open sea,"
but again, you begin to
see all these ideas on maps
and it just becomes impossible
to get rid of the idea
until explorers
unfortunately have
to go and live or die,
suffer, at any rate
to prove the theory.
Somebody who was captivated
by Petermann's ideas
was this guy, the third richest
man in New York at the time,
the publisher and editor of the
largest newspaper in the world,
the New York Herald.
This is James Gordon
Bennett Jr. who
was this Gilded Age
character, a spoiled brat,
a guy who got pretty much
everything he wanted,
a reckless adventurer
himself, a lover of spectacle.
He was the youngest commodore
of the New York Yacht Club.
He won the first
transatlantic yacht race.
He was famous for
driving coaches
around Manhattan
nude at midnight.
He publicly urinated
into a grand piano
at a party, a salon in New
York, which got him ostracized
from New York society.
And so he said a plague
on all your houses.
I'm moving to France.
So he ran his newspaper by
transatlantic cable from Paris.
Then he created
"The Paris Herald,"
which became "The
International Herald
Tribune," which
still exists and is
the last remnant of his empire.
Anyway, you can't
invent a character
as outsized or as
grand as Gordon Bennett
Jr. This was his newspaper,
a very influential paper,
important paper also
because he believed
not only in reporting the
news but creating spectacles
that would generate more and
more news and big blockbuster
stories.
He had all these fetishes.
For example, he was
really into Pomeranians.
He had hundreds of them.
I've seen a lot of dogs
here on the Google campus,
but he was in a particular
thing about Pomeranians
and consulted them for
various pieces of advice.
He was also interested in owls.
He had stuffed
owls, living owls.
Owls were his personal symbol
and the symbol of the paper.
This is the headquarters, which
shows owls on the eaves there.
And it was interesting.
The eyes of the owls
lit up with red lights,
and then they would
wink at you at night.
One of his many yachts,
this is the Lysistrata,
which had a 200 seat theater.
It had a Turkish bath.
And it had padded stalls
for his dairy cows
so he could have fresh cream
every morning for breakfast.
So this is the Gilded
Age, just tremendous sums
of money, certain
individuals who
had and were able to wield a
lot of power with this money.
And he pretty much
got what he wanted.
Now, my wife and I,
of course we felt we
had to go to Paris to
research Gordon Bennett.
And this is one of
his mansions in Paris,
a villa on the south
of France near Monaco
where he kept the Lysistrata.
We barged our way into the
house and there's still
people living there.
And they knew all about Bennett.
There were signs of
Bennett everywhere,
including owls all
over the place.
Bennett's also
famous for bringing
international ballooning
to the forefront.
He created this balloon
race which still exists,
the Bennett Cup.
So that's one of his legacies.
But he's most famous
for sending this guy--
this is Henry Morgan Stanley--
to Africa to find Livingston.
Livingston, I presume.
Livingston wasn't really lost.
He didn't really
need to be found,
but it made for a
great spectacle,
and a great series of dispatches
in "The New York Herald."
So really, Bennett was
looking for an encore
to Stanley Livingston when he
began to cultivate this idea
bank rolling an expedition
to the North Pole
to test the theories
of August Petermann.
He hired this guy to
lead the expedition.
This is George Washington
DeLong, the commander
of the Jeanette, a graduate
of the Naval Academy,
someone who had
been to Greenland,
had devoted the rest of his
life to trying to figure out
this planetary enigma.
What's at the North Pole?
He wanted to be
the first to do it,
and to do it for his
country, and for his Navy,
and for science.
Bennett purchased
this vessel, renamed
it the Jeanette after his
sister Jeanette Bennett.
And DeLong sailed
it around the Horn
from France to San
Francisco in 1878.
And in San Francisco,
it was massively
reinforced for the ice,
practically rebuilt.
And then they begin to stuff
it with all the latest American
inventions, including
Edison's lights, which
had just been designed.
They were still being perfected.
They weren't quite
ready as it turned out.
Telephone equipment from
Alexander Graham Bell,
telegraph equipment.
They wanted to be able
to communicate over
vast expanses of the ice.
Many, many, many kegs
of Budweiser beer.
They had a state
of the art library.
They had an organ.
They knew they were
going into the ice,
and this was going to
be a long, long voyage.
They had enough food
for three years.
And they left San Francisco
in the summer of 1879.
20,000 people were there to
celebrate and to send them off
into the Arctic.
Yeah, you had a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, just
wondering how many people
were on the ship.
HAMPTON SIDES: 33 men,
Captain DeLong and 32 men.
They headed north past Alaska.
That last stop was Alaska, where
they picked up 40 dogs and two
Inuit .
Hunters It was a very
international cast
of characters.
There were five or
six Naval officers.
There was a surgeon.
There was a meteorologist.
There was a naturalist.
And there was an
ice pilot, someone
who had a career really
in the Arctic as a whaler.
And there were two
Chinese cooks that
had been hired in
Chinatown in San Francisco.
So it was a motley crew of
individuals heading north
to test Petermann's theories.
Went through the Bering Strait,
through the Chukchi Sea,
past Wrangel Island.
They didn't find a
warm water current.
They did not find
the open polar sea.
What they found was
ice, a lot of it.
They got stuck in the
ice in September of '79
and began to drift in the ice
in a northwesterly direction,
and they drifted for
two years-- two years.
About a mile a day.
Every day is more or less like
the next, sort of a Groundhog
Day kind of thing.
And it presented an interesting
dilemma for me as a writer
because I didn't know
exactly how to tackle
the problem of those two years.
So I did something I didn't
think I would ever do,
which is kind of
a cinematic thing.
I had a little break at
the end of one chapter,
had a next section and
just said "one year later."
Because every day was almost
identical to the next.
So during these
two years, DeLong
had men out every day
measuring the ice,
taking lots of measurements
of barometric pressure,
temperature, the specific
gravity-- all kinds of things.
It was like floating or
drifting ice station, Arctic
ice station, really-- as
they worked their way north.
During this two
year period, the men
really get to know each
other, a lot of togetherness.
And some of the
characters really
emerge as real striking
characters in the book.
And I grew to know
these men, to love them,
sometimes to hate them
while I was writing them.
Some of the ones
that really emerged--
this is Melville the engineer,
a distant relative of Herman
Melville the writer.
An amazing man who
could fix anything.
And believe me, everything went
wrong during this expedition
and he was called upon.
For example, the
ship was constantly
leaking as the
ice was strangling
the whole of the vessel.
And so he devised a
series of windmills
to bring up all
the excess water.
Kept the ship afloat
for those two years.
This is Melville
as an old man when
he became engineer of the
entire US Navy and ultimately
a Rear Admiral.
There's Collins,
the Irishman, who
was the meteorologist and
the scientist onboard.
Interesting man, brilliant
man, but unfortunately he
had a propensity
for delivering puns,
like really, really bad puns.
And he couldn't help himself.
Now that's fine.
We've all been around
people like that
for two days or something.
That might be fine.
This was two years.
Everyone wanted to kill Collins.
There was Ambler
the surgeon, who
saw every kind of malady
you could imagine,
particularly vitamin
deficiencies.
There was lead poisoning.
There was polar bear
liver ingestion problems.
I guess that's vitamin
A. He saw it all
and had to be quite
creative in treating
these various ailments.
One of the ailments
that he had to treat
was Danenhower's
case of syphilis.
Turns out that
Danenhower, who was
the navigator and a
brilliant man, also
a graduate of the Naval
Academy, it turned out
that he had syphilis.
And it manifested itself in the
form of an eye condition called
syphilitic iritis,
which required
dozens and dozens of operations
without anesthesia down
in the ship.
And he had he could not
tolerate any light whatsoever.
So he had to wear these goggles
the entire voyage, somewhat
symbolizing this voyage, this
doomed voyage, that you have
essentially a blind navigator.
Not a good thing.
So they drifted though.
The first year was kind of like
this, just all over the place.
They circled back on
themselves many times, which
was extremely frustrating.
But finally the
drift smoothed out
and they worked their
way to the Northwest.
DeLong by this point
had completely given up
on the open polar sea theory.
He was cursing
Petermann's name, but he
thought he might not
sail to the North Pole,
but he might drift
there in the ice
if the ship, which had
been massively reinforced,
if the ship could
withstand the pressure,
he thought they might
drift to the North Pole
because they were heading
in the right direction.
He had dogs.
He thought maybe he
could get out on the ice
and make a dash for it.
Every day, as I
mentioned earlier,
the men were out
on the ice taking
measurements of everything.
And the log books, which ended
up in the National Archives
in Washington, they're very
heavy folio size books.
When I was reading them,
I was just thinking, gosh.
The journey that
these books took
to get into the
National Archives.
They're heavy.
They're cumbersome.
DeLong had to make some
strategic decisions
about keeping them as
things go from bad to worse
during the expedition.
But there they are.
But when I was reading them,
I was thinking, you know,
this is terrible.
What a waste of all this energy,
all this data, just hundreds
and hundreds and
hundreds of pages
of data about the
condition of the Arctic.
And I thought what a waste.
But then I found out that NOAA,
in tandem with a group called
Old Weather, has been
taking the DeLong journals,
and digitizing all this data,
and using it, ultimately,
to study the condition
of the Arctic.
Because when you talk
about global warming,
one of the problems they've
always had is no one really
knows what the condition of
the ice was 150 years ago.
Because to do that, you'd
have to go to a time machine
back to the 1800s.
You'd have to ram
yourself in the ice.
You'd have to drift for
two years in the ice
and take daily measurements,
even hourly measurements.
No one would do that, right?
Well someone did, and it's
George DeLong and his men.
And this is a
stretch of the Arctic
no one had ever
been through before.
And these the log books are
proving extremely valuable now
in these studies
that are going on.
When I do these
narratives, I like
whenever possible to travel to
the places I'm writing about.
This story mostly takes place in
the Arctic sections of Russia.
So I got myself a
really bad haircut
and I went to Moscow first
to get a bunch of permits.
Because unfortunately,
I couldn't just
go across from Alaska.
I was going to a lot
restricted areas.
So a "National
Geographic" fixer person
helped me get these
permits in Moscow.
And then I flew-- what is it?
Eight, Nine time zones east?
All away to the east
coast of Siberia to Anadyr
where I picked up this
Russian ice breaker--
it's not quite fully
an ice breaker.
It's a reinforced
vessel-- And headed north.
I thought it was
pretty ridiculous
that I had to travel
13,000 miles to look
at my own country, Alaska.
Heading north,
waving at Sarah Palin
as I went along the
northeast coast of Siberia.
Amazing place.
Mostly uninhabited.
We did stop at this one
village where they had just
killed a whale, and they were
having a summer festival,
and invited us ashore.
And we stayed there
for a few hours.
I took this with an iPhone.
But there were soldiers with
Kalashnikovs that didn't really
want us to be there.
They ushered us back
to the ship and we
headed north in the direction
of Wrangel Island, which
is where we were going.
There was a French
documentary crew
that was doing something
about woolly mammoths.
There were various
atmospheric scientists.
And then there was just a
whole bunch of intense birders,
like really, really
into birding.
Professional birders almost.
As we headed north, we
encountered more and more ice
until we got through this place.
This is looking straight down
from the bow of the ship.
And I just took this
again with an iPhone.
But it gives you some
sense of how quickly
the ice give can build up.
And this is in the
month of August.
So that brought us
to a complete halt.
We had to back up and
refigure our course.
But we eventually
reach our destination,
which was Wrangel Island.
Wrangel Island is a
very interesting place.
It's been called the
Galapagos of the high north.
It's got a huge amount
of wildlife-- Pacific
walrus, and snowy owls, and
snow geese, and Arctic fox,
and polar bears-- lots
and lots of polar bear.
August Petermann thought
that it was a continent.
It had only been glimpsed
by some Arctic whalers,
and it looked pretty large.
And he had this grand theory
that it was actually Greenland,
that Greenland came
up over, not quite
the pole but near the pole, and
all the way to the other side.
And that this was the
tip of Greenland--
another one of his
obviously wrong ideas,
but an interesting
place nonetheless.
It's uninhabited.
There are four Russian
rangers who live
there, are stationed there.
And when we came ashore in
these little Zodiac rafts,
these Russian rangers were
so happy to see us, so happy
to see fresh human life.
And we were happy
that the two or three
cabins that there were all
reinforced on the windows
there with bear guards.
Because there are
polar bears everywhere.
They congregate in larger
and larger numbers there
because during the summer, the
ice is increasingly unreliable.
And this is one of the only
scraps of land for thousands
of miles in any direction.
So this is one of the
places that they go.
I was there with a photographer
named Sergey [? Gorshkov ?]
who has been going to
Wrangel for over a decade,
taking these amazing wildlife
pictures for "National
Geographic Magazine and
a story that I wrote
that came out in March of 2013.
Arctic fox puppy.
They're constantly battling
over these snow geese eggs.
Sometimes, the geese win.
Sometimes, the foxes win.
Musk ox.
Also excellent facial hair.
So that's Wrangel Island.
It's an extraordinary place
and was one of the goals
that DeLong was reaching for.
When he realized that he was
going to be stuck in the ice,
he then began to hope, well,
at least I can land on Wrangel
and explore Wrangel.
But he was able to get there.
The ice took him up, and over,
and around it too quickly.
So he never landed on it.
Another thing about
Wrangel is it's
believed to be the
last place on Earth
where woolly mammoths lived
some 3,000 years after they
became extinct on the mainland.
So you see tusks all over the
island in riverbeds like this.
And Sergey just took
this shot of me.
I tried to fit it
into my overnight bag.
It wouldn't fit.
It's extraordinary though.
You these just
everywhere you go.
DeLong did not reach Wrangel,
but another American vessel
did reach it that
summer of 1881.
They were looking for the
Jeannette at that point.
They wanted to get
some tidings of what
had happened to the
Jeanette because it
had been gone for two years.
Onboard that vessel
was the father
of the American environmental
movement, John Muir, who
then was a young newspaperman.
And he wrote beautifully about
the search for the Jeanette
that summer of 1881.
He becomes a pretty
important character
in the middle of the book.
After Wrangel Island, I went
on to other parts of Russia,
including the Lena Delta,
which is by some counts
the largest delta in the world.
The Lena River is
a massive river
that empties into the Arctic
Ocean in central Siberia.
And I wanted to go to a place
called America Mountain.
400 miles north of
the Arctic Circle,
in the middle of nowhere,
in the middle of this delta,
is a place called America
Mountain, known there still
to this day as America mountain.
It's a monument that was built
in the 1880s to the Jeanette.
It took me forever to get there.
I did a story for
"Outside Magazine"
that got me up the river.
I had to get on riverboat,
and then a smaller boat,
and then finally a raft.
And then finally
at the end, I just
had to start wading
across all this water,
swatting mosquitoes constantly.
It was the most mosquito
infested place I've ever been.
We finally found
America mountain
and got to the top of it, and
found the monument more or less
as it had been left
from the 1880s.
That's taken about 2:00
or 3:00 in the morning,
that photograph.
It doesn't get dark in
the middle of summer.
Anyway, back to the
historical story.
So all through 1880 and 1881,
the men of the Jeannette
are drifting in a
northwesterly direction.
But finally in June of
1881, it becomes clear
that the ship is not going
to withstand the pressure.
DeLong doesn't have much time.
He can tell the ship is sinking.
He gets all his
stuff out on the ice.
And a lot of decisions
had to be made
about what to bring
because if he could tell
it was going fast.
And finally it did sink to the
bottom of the Arctic Ocean.
This is a French
painting that maybe
makes it a little more
heroic-looking than it actually
was.
But it sank to the bottom,
and DeLong and his 32 men
and 40 dogs are out on the ice
with their three open boats,
small whale boats,
with no other choice
but to drag these boats
and their few belongings
south to the nearest landmass,
which was the central Arctic
coast of Siberia.
Now, we know exactly
where the Jeanette sank.
DeLong took exact
measurements when it sank,
and it's in Arctic waters,
not very far from the DeLong
Islands, because DeLong and his
men discovered three islands.
And there's a group
of scientists,
both in Russia and in the
United States, NOAA scientists,
also the US Navy and a Russian
group of scientists as well
as the Russian
Geographical Society.
They're all interested
in finding the wreck
and photographing it,
and maybe bringing up
some relics, including those
lights of Edison's that didn't
work, and also the photographs.
All the photographs
that were taken
of this expedition on glass
plates went down with the ship.
So there's a movement now.
Even though our
relationship with Russia
officially is not
very good, there
is a movement to try to build
an expedition for next summer.
So we'll see how that goes out.
I'm very excited about
it and want to go.
OK, so in the summer of
1881, back in America,
what was happening?
Well, first thing, Bennett
had decided that summer it
was time to bring the
sport from England that
was known as tennis
to the United States
and introduce it to the country.
So he built this
enormous palace.
It's called the Newport
Casino in Rhode Island.
It's now the international
Hall of Fame for Tennis.
So while the men are
out on the ice cap,
Bennett is back in
Rhode Island introducing
tennis to the United States
and not suffering so much.
He invites DeLong's wife,
Emma DeLong, up to Newport
for some tennis and yachting.
The Gilded Age, you know?
It's a good time.
And Emma deLong becomes
a pretty important,
I'd say a very
important character,
in the middle and end of the
book for a variety of reasons.
Mainly, she wrote beautifully.
She wrote these beautiful,
beautiful letters,
and I had this rather
amazing experience, which
I think historians dream about.
Historians dream
of this thing where
you find a descendant of
one of your main characters.
And that descendant
tells you, hey, you know,
I just happen to have this trunk
full of letters in my attic.
Would you please come
and take it off my hands?
And that's exactly
what happened.
I heard about-- actually
cold called this woman
Catherine DeLong in Connecticut.
She said she had this
trunk full of letters,
and it was the personal
papers of Emma DeLong.
Please take them.
Give them-- donate them to a
library somewhere eventually.
But this is me and Catherine
DeLong at the Explorers
Club in New York City, which is
an amazing place, the Explorers
Club.
Lots of taxidermy.
But she loaned me these papers.
And in the papers were
all kinds of things,
love letters all from
the courtship days
of Emma and George.
But also these
letters that she wrote
in the summer of 1880
and 1881 and sent
north by way of
these Arctic whalers
in the hope that
somehow, some way,
they would reach her husband.
And they're beautiful,
beautiful letters.
And it really
becomes a love story
in the middle
portion of the book.
One of those letters she
sent by way of Greenland.
And it ended up in a hut in
far, far northern Greenland.
And Robert Pearey on his way
to the North Pole found it.
And he knew immediately
who it was from.
And it still had the
red wax seal on it,
which you can see there.
And he stuffed it in his furs,
and eventually got it back
to New York City, and hand
delivered it to Emma DeLong.
So that letter is in that trove.
So during the summer of
1881, DeLong and his men
struggle over the ice.
They have just the
summer to do this.
They know that
once winter comes,
they're not going to survive it.
They don't have
enough food, so they
have to constantly hunt
for polar bear, and walrus,
and seal, which they prove
to be very successful at.
You'll be glad to know that
the dogs are not eaten.
They have plenty of
other things to eat.
My editor wants us to
do a companion book that
would be the Jeanette
Cookbook, like permitted walrus
fetus, all kinds of good stuff.
But they survive, and
in fact, they thrive.
And in a weird way, this is
maybe the happiest period
of the expedition.
Because they're
struggling every day.
They're in excruciating
pain, but they're
getting tremendous
exercise and they're
working for this common goal.
DeLong organizes the
men extremely well
into these three teams.
They compete against each
other, and they work their way
south over the ice.
And they are on
the ice for 92 days
till they finally
come to open water.
Most of these Arctic stories
have the perfect trifecta
of scurvy, mutiny, and
of course cannibalism.
And this has none
of those, and I
think it's a testament to
the leadership of DeLong
and the camaraderie
of this group
that they held this thing
together for those 92 days.
And it's an extraordinary
survival story, really,
in this part of the story.
So this shows their
general path south.
It starts out that
they are going south.
You see here they go north.
And that's not because
they didn't have a compass.
It's because they
struggled south and had
a really productive
period of about two weeks
where DeLong thought they
were making great progress,
but then he took a
positional reading,
and they realized that the
ice was drifting faster north
than they were moving south.
The whole ice pack
was moving, and so it
was a Sisyphean effort.
They were moving backwards.
Then it evens out here, and
then they work their way south.
They discover this
island right here,
Bennett Island, which they
declared American soil,
raised the American flag.
And just as John
Muir's group, when
they landed on Wrangel Island,
they declared American soil.
But the United States
didn't do much to press
their claim on that land, and
it's now Russian territory.
So they worked their way
through these islands
that are called
the New Siberians,
working their way
towards the Lana Delta.
When they finally
encounter open water,
they want to put their
whale boats in the water.
But it turns out they
are not seaworthy.
Dragging them all over the ice,
banging them up the whole time
had created leaks.
So Melville and his
carpenters rebuild these boats
using driftwood,
whalebone, walrus tusks,
whatever they can find.
They somehow patch them
together and they finally
set sail in late
August in open water
when they encounter a massive
gale, practically a hurricane.
And the three boats are
separated from each other.
And really that is where I end
my talk, because the last 150
pages, 200 pages of
the book are about what
happens to those three boats
and the very different fates
of the three boats as
they work their way
toward land and toward safety.
So that's the story
of the Jeanette
as they work their way, really,
towards this delta, a place
that is said to be about
the size of three Florida
Everglades, except a frozen
Everglades, a labyrinth.
So these men are
trying to find safety
and trying to find each other
in incredibly tangled maze
and this incredible landscape.
So that is the story
of the Jeanette.
Don't Google it.
This is Google, but
don't Google it.
You can find out
what happens, but I
believe this story is much more
powerful, much more haunting,
and much more
beautiful if you don't
know the fate of these men
and what happens to them.
Don't read the New
York Times Book
Review, which is a complete
plot summary of my book.
I think you'll really find the
last 200 pages or so extremely
gripping.
And it's a great survival story.
It's a great story about
men who stick together
through incredible
strife and striving,
and are incredibly
loyal to each other
as they try to
make it to safety.
So that's the story
of the Jeanette.
I'd love to hear from you.
Any questions from
the audience about how
I write these books, how I
research these books, narrative
history?
Any questions at all?
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Why do you think
this tale hasn't really
gotten the same kind of
publicity as like Franklin
or Shackleton or any of these
other disaster explorers?
HAMPTON SIDES: It's
a good question,
and I've thought about it a lot.
And I think that there's
a combination reasons.
I mean, one is that I think
the British are much better
than the Americans
at celebrating
their noble failures.
In fact, they love
those stories.
In America, we like to win.
We like we like to
achieve and succeed.
And I think Perry, Perry reached
the North Pole although that's
contested in 1909 with Henson.
And we love that story.
That's the story that we
focus on a little bit more.
The Franklin Expedition
was a colossal failure.
Shackleton wasn't
exactly a failure
in the sense that no one died.
But they didn't reach
their destination.
I think that's one
of the reasons.
Another thing is that all
the photographs went down
with the ship.
We're a very visual culture.
Those Shackleton
pictures are amazing.
They are truly
amazing, and I think
one of the reasons why
Shackleton is so well known
is because of those
extraordinary images.
I think it's also just
kind of a burnout thing.
I mean, this was
so big in its time.
It produced so many
different books.
And all the survivors
had their own accounts.
And Emma DeLong had her account.
DeLong's journals were published
and became bestselling books.
So it did have its day,
but it just burned out
and then tell
between the cracks.
And then Pearey came
along, and other explorers
who took the story farther.
So those are some
of the reasons.
Maybe there wasn't a good writer
who came along to deal with it.
And I hope I've begun
to make a dent in this.
Because I do truly believe it
is one of the great survival
stories, one of the great
adventure stories of all time.
And it is sort of the American
Shackleton, if you will.
AUDIENCE: So two very
different questions actually.
What you had said made
me think of another one.
What else would you put in the
Pantheon of great adventures?
And then the other
unrelated question
is how does the process
of writing this book
compare to your other books?
HAMPTON SIDES: Pantheon of
great adventure stories?
Wow, that's tough.
There's certainly Nansen, who
I mentioned at the beginning.
What's extraordinary
about Nansen
is he tried to duplicate
the Voyage of the Jeanette
in a differently designed
vessel, the Fram, this boat
that he had built. And what
happened was with Nansen,
Fridtjof Nansen from
Norway, he found out
that some relics of the
Jeanette had washed up
on shore in Greenland about
five years after the Jeanette
voyage.
And one of them was a
pair of seal skin pants
that had on the inseam a little
tag that said George Washington
DeLong.
And he realized that
meant that these pants had
come up and over the
pole and had popped out
on the other side in Greenland.
And so he surmised,
correctly as it turned out,
that that was the
prevailing pattern
of the wind and the drift
of the ice, the currents.
And so George Washington DeLong
didn't make it the North Pole,
but his pants did.
And he got to thinking,
well, why don't I
just ram myself in
the ice in exactly
the same place that DeLong's
men did, and drift in the ice?
He wasn't looking for the
open polar sea anymore.
Just use the ice, work with it.
And that's what he did.
And his adventure--
"Furthest North"
is the book that he wrote--
is an extraordinary story.
They got very close
to the North Pole.
realized he wasn't
going to reach it.
And he got out on the ice
with his dogs and another guy.
And they made a
dash for the pole.
They didn't quite make it.
They turned around,
couldn't find the Fram.
MALE SPEAKER: He's
unofficially called
the Father of Oceanography
as well, Nansen.
HAMPTON SIDES: Yeah, yeah.
I mean, he was a
brilliant scientist.
He was a statesman,
and he ultimately
won the Nobel Peace Prize.
Extraordinary man.
So I put Nansen's
adventures at the very top
of all the Arctic adventurers
that I've read about.
Of course, there's Amundsen.
The Scandinavians,
the Norwegians
are the best at this kind
of exploration, I think.
The question is how did this
differ from my other books?
You know, the
biggest difference is
I had to go farther afield
than any of my other books.
I like to travel to
wherever the story takes
place, but this one, it was
really hard to get to Russia.
I mean, luckily there
was this little window
where our relationship with
Russia was pretty good.
And I was able to
get those permits
and go to these
restricted areas.
It was expensive
though, and complicated,
and logistically involved.
But I love doing that.
That's the fun part of
doing these stories.
And it pays off in so many ways
in the way you write about ice,
or you write about
the tundra, or any
of these passages I have.
It gives you a confidence
about describing landscape
that you couldn't otherwise get.
And I also just wanted to
understand the Gilded Age.
It's just such a fascinating
period, you know?
America's beginning
to look familiar.
It's not quite there yet.
It's still a brawling
teenager that's trying
to figure out what it.
It has a lot of ambition.
It has a lot of
technological prowess,
but it's still not
quite a mature country.
And so you get
people like Bennett.
You get people like Edison
and all these inventions
that are happening.
And it's trying to flex its
muscles on the world stage.
It's a really interesting time.
All right.
I'm going to sign some
books if you like.
Thank you very much.
Pleasure being here.